[Musik]
das ist die geschichte von patrick fuchs
einem erfolgreichen banker aufgewachsen
in effretikon bei winterthur jetzt
wohnhaft in burma im land der goldenen
tempel
[Musik]
damit wird dann wieder was zustande und
das macht mir so viel mal wie man alt
ist mit 430
430 aber in hohem maße tue riskiere
entspannt
doch fuchs ist nicht nur banker sondern
auch ein gefeierter filmstar namens
abdullah
[Musik]
auf
der nüchterne geschäftsmann patrick
fuchs unterwegs in burma seit wenigen
monaten lebt er hier die blutige
militärdiktatur ist weg fast jeder tag
bringt jetzt eine neue reform
von der mannschaft möchte stabiles land
haben und das hat mir sehr gut gemacht
nachts offen reden lied erklang spät das
gespürt medien hat die zensur
angeschafft wurden staatliche tätige hat
man früher einen rehbock schmunzelt
jetzt auch sagen das sind eigentlich
sehr gut die informationsquellen
fuchs berät geschäftsleute die in burma
investieren möchten
im april letzten jahres fanden die
ersten echten freien wahlen statt
seither hat sich viel verändert in burma
essen mit kunden für patrick fuchs sohn
einer brasilien und eines schweizers ist
dies das eine leben
doch wenn er sich in der stadt zeigt
wird es dem nüchternen geschäftsmann der
filmstar und tula es ist das andere
leben von patrick fuchs
hinter seinem rücken wird getuschelt
ganz diskret wie in der schweiz
im bescheidenen schweizer gefällt die
burmesische zurückhaltung
[Applaus]
schauspieler
sie kennen wie die meisten chinesen nur
das andere leben von patrick fuchs das
als schauspieler amt
das heißt seine firma sie ist ein
anderes bürgerliches leben
14 angestellte beschäftigte er sein
großer vorteil als sohn einer musischen
mutter spricht er fließend die
landessprache
in der schweiz studierte fuchs zuerst
maschinenbau dann ökonomie danach
arbeitete er als banker in zürich mit
diesen erfahrungen ist er in burma
offiziell myanmar genannt ein gefragter
mann
zu besuch in der schweiz bei seinen
eltern
es ist dort wo ich ruft woche zu binden
wir sind dort tätig bei der eigentlichen
präsentation hat im märz
seine mutter ist eine dumme sein vater
martin fuchs lernte sie vor 40 jahren in
wurm erkennen
und so wuchs der kleine patrick in zwei
verschiedenen kulturen auf
[Musik]
ich habe mit ihm
schweizerdeutsch trecker und ich rede
mir meine frau schließlich aus
eigentlich dreisprachig aufgewachsen
und genau so martina winter die sprache
zu erklären maximal sieben sprachen
zweckbau sie natürlich cvp verblasst
[Musik]
seine mutter hat kürzlich ein riesiges
stück land außerhalb der stadt rangun
gekauft
ihre arbeit an pflanzen hier mangos und
gummibäume
[Musik]
patrick fuchs zeigt wie die angestellten
leben sind süße fotoarbeiten sind
verteilt im ganzen land natürlich die
dringlichkeit wo verschiedene city haben
es nicht auch heimathaus jahren schrieb
okay die lage und die bescheidenen
finanzen ist ja ja was ganz ganz london
vertritt
meine mutter hat aber ein plan mit
ist ein tag wie physik so
bot mit
beton und sie wird das dann mit dem
anderen auch jetzt haben wir schon zwei
oder drei stück und sport immer die
andere langsame sätze
[Musik]
heiser waren sie
schon das dms heimisches
blutig verständigt inzwischen kehrt also
dann pro tournee vom im
wald zu einheimischen sehr gern da
einfach zum nur gesundes gemüse
und wie
wunderschön fliegt
bleibe das mit der film darf macht hand
ein merklich zurückgefahren hat
sein film schatten der vergangenheit
lautet der titel einer eigenproduktion
[Musik]
mit ihm als hauptdarsteller buchs nahm
dafür einen kredit von 200000 franken
auf der film wurde in burma zum großen
erfolg und er zum star
[Musik]
das aloha
eine romantische liebesgeschichte
und gleichzeitig ein krimi mit viel
action
ja ich glaub man will film lockte man
gern film hat dann hat man ganz viele
ideen
[Musik]
hat man vor dem willen irgendeine bis
von anderen wegen app ist man natürlich
auch das war spannend die story
dass man das ganz neue findet den film
vor irgend ein bisschen kopiert
bis übernommen aber das hat doch
irgendwo da wieder jemand drin der
element in wohlgefallen hand anderen
film und die hat untergebracht
wir fielen spiel teilweise in der
schweiz wuchs mimt einen reichen banker
der in einem komplott verwickelt wird
[Musik]
die lebensgeschichte
relevant wo ähnlich sind ich hoffe der
bank schaffte die hauptfigur im
wissenschaftszug von der bank
erlebte
das schwierige stück organisatorisch sie
zum alte filmemacher
zum mitbringen zum visum büro zum audio
locations planen das ist nicht einfach
sie hat viel art braucht und zwar mit
dem regisseur der bekannte schauspieler
schaffen
dass ein politischer film im westen im
schnee der berge spielt natürlich normal
faszinierender und lud schlacht nicht
sehr häufig auf das tätig vom film die
schöne landschaft und sind einige
jahrgang schweiz wachsen will
[Musik]
peking
die
fuchs drehte hauptsächlich mit einem
burmesischen team ergänzte es aber mit
schweizer kameraleuten
er führte co regie und schnitt im film
zum größten teil selber wunder ein jahr
lang immer spät abends nach der arbeit
auf der bank manchmal drohte ihm das
ganze über den kopf zu wachsen
zwischen ihren option sie will
irgendwann nicht mehr zu wie drin und
zwar auf gibt dann verliert man ja alles
hat sich gelohnt sind das auffangen das
heißt so gerne ich jetzt nicht dankbar
aber es ist schon so dass ich nicht
motiviert ich bin also zum teil ich
wirklich keine lust kam zum web is
machen nicht während der dreharbeiten
vor allem werden die postproduktion
trainer bittet soziales burg sie hat
auch sehr spaß gemacht aber nach dann
wenn man schneidet wallfahrt korrekturen
macht weil mit ton arbeiten macht ist
das eigentlich eine langweilige job und
in deutschland nach mannschaft auf die
bank geschafft daraus machen ähnlich
motiviert sie eine szene gedreht zum
büro seines vaters wuchs musste auf
jeden fall ein achten
die familie hatte sehr kurze wieder drei
aber am ende mein freundeskreis hat mich
unterstützt hat ist das hat man sie eher
cool
wenig unterstützt
2004 wollte einen film drehen ich habe
ja wir haben nicht so viel zeit und es
ist wichtiger so dann lieber wenn du
einmal zeit hast dann können wir so habe
ich ihm gesagt und nach dem doktorarbeit
er hat mehr zeitung ich habe ihm gesagt
jetzt kannst du marke schweiz von ihren
zwei wochen ferien so weit gehen einfach
unterstützt ihre natürlichkeit erfahrung
in filmen und ein making ofs gemacht mit
handkamera und auf der anderen seite
hania szene aus
kanada sind es zehn
rost liegenschaften verschiebbare
kernbank
[Musik]
der film mit seinem mystischen
hintergrund begeisterte das publikum
über 300.000 besucher sahen ihn sich an
[Musik]
fielmann zionistische komponente wo es
darum beratung wieder gebohrt um regel
aber und kienbaum passierte bis wichtig
da erinnert sich
hauptausstellungen
entscheidend vom frühjahr gelassen
[Musik]
da bin ich gefahren hatte war mehrmals
kontakt
da würde ich jetzt gerne im film
geht dann immer ganz gleich ob
[Musik]
wir sind in china aufnahmen eines
freundes von patrick fuchs buchs wird
hier als bester ausländischer darsteller
ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
eine art chinesischer oscar
die fantastische geschichte von tura
alias patrick fuchs
[Musik]
sie hat sein leben komplett verändert
bekanntheit spielt da doch lachte große
rolle es öffnet natürlich
lügt tracht vergangen die meiste liegt
kann ich mich schon also wenn ich jetzt
ruft minister
treffens der zentralbanker fall kann ich
mich irgendwie schon dann sag ich ja
herr minister 1000 das mache ich finde
es hier die dem geschäftsfeld etwas
machen und dann sagte er zu mir und
dann hilft bei der tour und das hilft
man sich natürlich an als schauspieler
will brisant sie der medica und jetzt
kann ich mich als journalist und jetzt
sage ich spiele zum geschäftsbereich
tätig und jetzt limitierung exhumieren
schreibt artikel über mich gesagt und
dann sagt er
die firma erwartet natürlich und das
macht spaß muss nicht so um
aufmerksamkeit kämpfen wie komme ich
automatisch über
und so ist er auch dabei als bundesrat
didier burkhalter burma besucht
der staatsbesuch vom bundesrat
burkhalter signalisiert die schweiz will
dabei sein bei der öffnung des landes
auch wirtschaftlich
eine zufällig anwesende schweizer
touristengruppe applaudiert
[Applaus]
in festanlass moderiert patrick fuchs
ein letzter kontrollgang bevor der
bundesrat eintrifft
es ist das mittlerweile her dass sie
reden sie natürlich
er spricht wie ein boom ise und schwitzt
wie ein schweizer
[Musik]
patrick fuchs alias der perfekte
botschafter und mittler zwischen den
kulturen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
visionen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im moment dominiert das leben des
geschäftsmannes patrick fuchs dann wird
er wieder der schauspieler auf tour
ich werde irgendwie drauf stocker war
nicht nach stabilen bringen und da muss
gespielt und ich muss sagen im moment
ganz geschafft so formiert das
minimieren man muss vor allem aber
wollen die firma mal verkauft könnte sie
das mit dem film machen mich wirklich
faszinierte aber ich bin es gerne mit
einem größeren budget noch viel mehr von
dem bestimmt was man machen kann
acht eu wandinger trailer aber das
braucht noch etwas machen
als schauspieler und tura verliebte er
sich
und im realen leben als patrick
funktionieren
[Musik]